Antarctica is a land of extremes
and it's got an incredible grand scale.
So it's very difficult to try and capture it with images.
Being a National Geographic photographer
creates an opportunity for me to document the world
and you don't know what you're going to uncover.
You are going into the unknown.
There's always a bit of nervous excitement.
To get to Antarctica we have to get across one of the
most treacherous crossings on the planet
which is the Drake Passage.
Antarctica is other-worldly.
Big mountain ranges
and endless seas of ice.
And it's a challenging place to document
because it feels like you can never really do it justice.
I'm trying to showcase this land of extremes.
How every single flake of snow
counts towards building that incredible landscape.
It's strange to think that something so light
can compact over thousands of years
and trap so much history in the glacier.
I like to be as prepared as I can be
but I want to leave myself open to
inspiration from the environment.
So the calving just happened and it's created a wave
and we can see it push up all the ice on to the beach.
There's these kind of beautiful coincidences that happen
and that's when those really special images
tend to eventuate.
I find that the colours in Antarctica
pull you out of yourself.
Yet it is the most present that we get to be.
You can see quite a lot of water pouring out of the glacier
We all know that Antarctica is deeply impacted
by climate change.
And I want to try and showcase that fragility
through the macro and the micro.
You can hear the ice releasing the air bubbles
and it sounds like popcorn.
So we are recording underwater
because most of the iceberg is under the surface
so this is going to give us a bit of a glimpse.
That was on Ultra Steady as well.
It's an electric feeling to
see these images that I have envisioned
and to suddenly see them come to life.
He's collecting all the little rocks
and he's creating a nest.
What I really love, especially with nature, is that
it reveals itself gently and a little bit by bit.
I think a big part of my work is
uncovering those moments.
When I capture an image that I feel like
encapsulates that moment.
It's a feeling of coming home.